welcome to this video playing Nico I
don't remember playing him often better
have played more than five times okay
guys going for them the center game yes
this is called um Bishop c4 Wow now I
completely forgot everything here Queen
g3 is what they normally do I don't know
about that move I vaguely remember that
that this is it that this is a move but
I don't know what it is what is my reply
them Knight a5 I think there's something
on the bishop them
yeah maybe I can gain some space there
this is a temple move
b5 before would be nice yeah forget this
in would be nice yeah it's a strange
position there with his Queen on g5
what's this the point Bishop to g5 maybe
yeah but even if you place that okay it
would be a problem if he goes night
Bishop g5 in 95 okay lets investors move
b5 Bishop g5 wait wait wait where's the
Queen going after night age 52 g five
probably okay okay and it's still play
that that cannot be bad ready
shoot g5
95 is very sharp
yeah the problem is he cannot really
take we cannot give me the open a file
this is some even bad form for tactical
reasons I think take stakes 95,000 I
takes d5 possibly for checkmates so he
has to move the the night and allow me
to take on a over that then set
surprising I thought night takes d5 is a
move at least then you cannot take my
queen can also start with the check
check Kingda to
okay let's start with that money you
cannot take my queen this is made this
show is frias than meat and what isn't
right it is Nate why what am i doing him
it might still work but it's not it's
not what I thought it is okay let's
let's not lose all nurse yeah we
definitely have something in this
position if I check him we can go to be
one which is what I did not appreciate
so I have to check start with that and
now i have i have checks the area quite
quite some interesting checks we take
the f goodnight III check Bishop e3
check is got King you one it's not clear
what my compensation yes so let's do
that and give this check check I can
always just take on da dat the end and
just play this position which will be
interesting still and where is he going
Kingda to its directly directly losing
so I'm going to take here right I have
to check the second piece so if i go go
to a 10 k probably i have to take use
this temper move here
night f form mm-hmm maybe if i take my f
seven porn is hanging which is a problem
really is a problem
I don't get get this other night news
king absolutely don't know if five night
h5 looks tricky yeah in my time it's
even more tricky so let's let's get
let's start to accelerate him
look 8 and 94 might be a dress right age
5 I can go g6 I think this is still ok I
mean relatively speaking i'm not
claiming i mean ok I'm ok in this
position in general I might I'm just
saying that I can maybe play it somehow
why didn't that take the other night I'm
weren't even would have been a bit more
interesting
can still be quite annoying in this in
this position b3 is not working here is
there any way to play for Winnie I don't
I don't really see it but should be 3 or
something that's probably nonsense
you can try to play forward look see one
or something when you have 30 seconds
be 30 vision t4 that looks kind of good
thread c2 and made check Andrew gay one
checkmate checkmate yeah so I said some
tricks there but it was that was lost
yeah for sure I had some had a viet
elucidation there i was really thinking
i can give up the Queen for the dance
that I can just do that and I'm fine but
that's not the case I really thought he
couldn't take I thought that is a maiden
but there is no mate but there is no
wait I saw that but I forgot that he can
go here and there is no checkmate them
this of course is made checkmate so very
much a strange and also not necessary
com points out c6 and black wins yeah
but how exactly chattox you should move
and then d5 what is d 5 doing it for
Queen f5 a compass on minus 6 so it
looks like a heavy decisive attack there
ok yeah so Jack was not working of
course check check no I'm struggling
with two pieces against the Queen yeah
compiz on plus two so wyd winds but
there is nothing nothing killing that
looks good though a calm suggestion also
keeping an eye on this now why should
win there just by material ok some of
this we repeat it a little bit again we
repeat it yeah he can he can play this
move that is quite strong no it is the
strong
what is the calm saying 95 no that's it
I just misread that looked if i miss the
computer suggestion okay for this
position yeah maybe that looks kind of
that looks bad can try a little bit but
now white is better here no question a
better I mean winning him this is I'm
not that I'm not sure about Bishop c4
and be three years I think giving it
away yeah but should be fine black wins
so I don't know he probably has to move
the look again look see one and then
maybe be three mm-hmm kind of at least
this looks a bit a bit tricky for
example the oops sorry the line that the
computer is giving this is actually
winning for black the line that the
computer is giving is this this is kind
of interesting cheek steaks & T I'm
pretty confident that black has decent
drawing chances this could be a fortress
not sure if wide will I be able to break
through on the Kings at them so I have
some chances now but it was basically
lost for most of it okay well thanks for
watching